a primeira coisa que meu pai fez quando
mudou para essa casa onde a minha
família vive até hoje na rua sagarana
nota de pneus aqui em são paulo foi
plantar esse psp roxo que estão vendo
essa foto
eu nasci quatro anos depois e foi
crescendo junto com essa área
eu sou filho temporão não tinha mais
criança em casa então ela era minha
amiga eu bati um papo com a árvore
ficava gripado nela o tempo todo
foi um tombo dessa área que abriga até
esta ganhei meus primeiros pontos e o
que eu vou trazer aqui pra vocês hoje
acho que é fruto desse amor dessa
relação com essa árvore e eu quero que
seja uma homenagem para ela também
porque hoje é o dia da árvore e é o dia
do meu ip roxo
só que as aves não estão só no começo no
centro da minha história pessoal
a gente tem árvores desempenham um papel
muito importante em todas as tradições
da humanidade em várias culturas em
várias tradições espirituais
a mais conhecida de todo mundo aqui
provavelmente essa água que ficava no
centro do jardim do paraíso mas também
tem uma ave muito importante por exemplo
hinduísmo que acredita que as raízes do
universo tão lá no céu
as folhas e frutos estão aqui na terra
somos nós é tudo que vivi o buda se
iluminou debaixo de uma área de 2.500
anos debaixo de uma figueira e ashoka
que foi o primeiro imperador indiano que
se converteu ao budismo quando ele
mandava emissários pra divulgar a
mensagem do budismo ele fazia uma muda
tirando um ramo dessa água e mandava
isso junto com esses missionários
eu tive a felicidade de poder visitar
este lugar em bodh gaya na índia que é o
lugar mais sagrado para os budistas de
todas as tradições e essa água está lá é
uma descendente da área original
exatamente da mesma espécie
o nome científico dessa figueira é fícus
religiosa isso é muito importante porque
conhecer é amar e amar e conhecer e se a
gente não consegue dar nome para as
coisas que a gente diz que gosta a gente
não gosta delas na verdade ea gente tem
que aprender a nomear para poder saber
como cuidar mas se isso é tão importante
para a humanidade porque a gente
continua desmatando
hoje a gente sabe que o desmatamento vai
agravar
vez mais o o desequilíbrio climático a
gente sabe que a nossa cidade está
passando sede por falta de árvores que a
gente tirou por que isso acontece
é muito comum a gente apontar para os
outros e fala não isso é ganância e só
porque tem gente má mas não é verdade
não a gente só está aqui porque a gente
destruiu muitas áreas as árvores são a
principal fonte de energia são a
principal fonte de matéria-prima para a
humanidade desde o começo da nossa
história então não são os outros que
derrubam aves somos nós que fazemos isso
e isso acontece ao longo da história e
isso se repete e se repete e o drama de
civilizações que entrar em declínio por
conta de destruir o meio ambiente de
destruir as árvores não é nenhuma
novidade e isso aconteceu muitas vezes
talvez o exemplo mais espectacular seja
da civilização maia e os pesquisadores
não tem dúvida de que eles construíam as
cidades de pedra esgotar os recursos
florestais em volta delas abandonavam e
um pra outra até que não tinha mais como
ele subsistirem e aqui estamos nós desde
o ano 1500 a gente aprendeu na escola
que o primeira atividade econômica
importante no nosso país foi derrubar
essa árvore
aliás o nosso país tem o nome de uma
árvore ea gente continua e continua e
continua e isso é que nós fizemos ao
longo dos últimos 500 anos a gente
destruiu a floresta comemora
biodiversidade do planeta a mata
atlântica tem uma biodiversidade muito
maior do que a amazônia ea gente
destruiu não sobrou quase nada e agora a
gente está destruindo a amazônia também
como é que a gente pode fazer para
reverter isso a revista noite o público
no início desse mês uma pesquisa que fez
um levantamento e talvez o mais preciso
do número de árvores que existem no
nosso planeta eles chegaram nessa cifra
astronômica de 3 trilhões de árvores mas
para dar uma ideia mais concreta do que
isso significa
isso significa que cada um de nós cada
ser humano tem 422 árvores
só que a gente está derrubando a gente
está derrubando 15 bilhões e 300 milhões
de árvores por ano para simplificar cada
um de nós perde duas árvores por ano
como é que a gente pode brincar isso
como é que a gente pode reverter esse
jogo isso é vital e cada um de nós cada
um de vocês nessa sala tem que salvar
suas duas árvores esse ano quando a
gente fala de conter o desmatamento no
brasil
normalmente todo mundo pensa na amazônia
que é onde essa luta se travando agora
de uma maneira mais encarniçada vamos
dizer assim e é uma luta fundamental
só que isso é lá longe isso é uma luta
para o governo ser uma luta pra polícia
é uma coisa muito complicada que a gente
pode fazer aqui onde a gente vive que a
gente pode fazer aqui na mata atlântica
eu na verdade fugi mudei com a minha
família para ele a bela isso faz 16 anos
porque eu não achava que eu poderia
criar meus filhos necessidade eu não
queria mais morar aqui eu não podia
abandonar completamente essa cidade
porque o meu trabalho aqui mas eu fui
criar meus filhos lá longe e lá eu vivo
num paraíso
a gente tem floresta a gente tem
cachoeiras no quintal de casa é o sonho
de todo mundo
só que lá também tem problemas né a
gente tem que resolver as coisas no
lugar que a gente está lá eu me envolvi
com a questão ambiental e essa montanha
com uma das mais altas que tem lá um
pique do bpp
a gente fez a regularização de uma
trilha de ecoturismo que leva lá pro
alto né
e vocês estão vendo aqui embaixo da
pedra tem uma região verde mais clara já
dentro do parque estadual de ilhabela
80% da área de gabriel um parque
estadual ela tem mata primária uma
floresta intocada no meio da ilha é uma
coisa incrível trabalhando nessa trilha
veio a idéia de recuperar a floresta e
puxa vai ser fácil recuperar a floresta
dentro do parque estadual mário
protegida e aí esse sonho começou a
andar ea gente criou então esse viveiro
de mudas de árvores nativas na chamada
viva floresta não apenas a gente queria
recuperar a floresta dentro do parque
estadual de ilhabela mas aquela região
tá sofrendo um monte de pressões
simultâneas o pré sal no estado de são
paulo está sendo explorado nas águas de
ilhabela o porto de são sebastião que
está para ser ampliado o estado sendo
duplicado enfim um monte de pressões um
monte de empreendimentos e todos os
empreendimentos a justiça obriga que
eles replantem floresta que ele recupere
áreas de preservação permanente então
haveria uma grande oportunidade lá de se
plantar árvores e de que isso fosse uma
atividade econômica a idéia original do
rio floresta criar um modelo é aprender
a tecnologia do plantio eo cultivo das
árvores mas também o modelo
o negócio envolveu uma receita que
depois comunidade de caiçaras ongs ou
qualquer pessoa interessada pudesse
criar vários viveiros na região e fazer
disso uma atividade econômica uma
atividade do bem só que as coisas são
bem mais complicadas do que a gente
imaginou não apenas plantar floresta
dentro de uma unidade de conservação no
brasil é quase impossível mas fazer de
um viveiro de mudas uma atividade
econômica é dificílimo né
tem um monte de problemas nesse caminho
o monte de coisas travam os processos de
restauração florestal né a gente chama
de reflorestamento reflorestamento é
utilizado pra menos né restauração
florestal fazer a floresta voltar para
um lugar que ela ocupava e os problemas
são muitos mas tem gente que ganha muito
dinheiro com isso alguns poucos viver os
vendem milhões de mudas por ano
os viveiros médios e principalmente os
pequenos sofrem muito e houve vários
deles fechando as portas
então do ponto de vista financeiro
floresta é o pior negócio que eu já fiz
na minha vida mas é a coisa mais legal e
mais querida e que me traz mais prazer e
por isso eu continuei ea gente foi
aprendendo e insistindo
um dos problemas que a gente tem para
administrar viver é o seguinte uma
floresta no hemisfério norte na europa e
nos estados unidos em 10 15 tipos de
árvore aqui na mata atlântica a gente
tem centenas e centenas ea legislação
exige que quem vai recuperar a floresta
tem que colocar aqui no estado de são
paulo pelo menos 80 espécies então
mensalidade que você recebe uma lista de
80 nomes científicos de árvores para
atender o pedido
ninguém consegue por isso os muito
grande tem uma chance mas os médios e
pequenos não
outro problema são as sementes é agente
coleta algumas das sementes que a gente
usa mas a maior parte a gente tem que
comprar tem poucas sementes no mercado
elas custam caríssimo e tem esse
problema de buscar também a
variabilidade de espécie tem outros
problemas também a muda é um produto em
que o frete mais caro que o produto tem
vários gargalos mas todo mundo que tá
nesse ramo acha que tem o dourado
chegando o novo código florestal que
cria uma obrigatoriedade de que os
proprietários rurais recupere as
chamadas áreas de preservação permanente
que a gente chama de app as beiras de
rio
aceite topo de morro coisa desse gênero
e realmente em algum momento isso vai
começar
é uma luta entre ambientalistas e
ruralistas houve um acordo bem ou mal o
fato é que em algum tempo esse negócio
vai começar a funcionar
só que aí vai haver o outro problema o
ministério do meio ambiente estima que
para recuperar todas a pt no brasil nós
vamos precisar de 60 milhões de mudas
como a capacidade produtiva dos vinhos
brasileiros é de 20 milhões
a gente vai demorar três mil anos então
é impossível a gente tem que virar esse
jogo e como no meio de tudo isso fazer
alguma coisa que seja o modelo de
negócio viável
aí foi que a eureka rubber bennesby
economia compartilhada que significa
isso
botar em rede as pessoas que são juntas
ea gente tinha desenvolvido para o viva
floresta a plataforma online para
facilitar nossa vida então criar um
banco de dados com todas as espécies
isso controla o nosso estoque recebe os
pedidos responde se eu tenho ou não
tenho tal tipo de ave e aí pô vamos
então compartilhar isso aqui com vários
viveiros oferecer isso como software
livre
isso começou a funcionar há um mês
finalmente a plataforma ficou pronta eu
já tenho mais cinco viveiros trabalhando
junto com a gente e tem outros viveiros
que estão na fila para entrar
só que na verdade é uma rede para
crescer do jeito que a gente precisa
crescer muito e rápido não poderia falar
só conviver estações engenheiro
florestais
a gente tinha que envolver todo mundo a
gente tem que poder envolver todos vocês
estão aqui como fazer isso
e foi aí que o meu ip esse é o mesmo na
frente da casa da minha mãe
florido eu cheguei lá ou será que eu vou
coletar semente e aí eu me dei conta que
a resposta estava ali diante do meu
nariz não apenas são paulo poderia ser
uma resposta pra eu poder coletar
sementes mas podia ser uma resposta até
para eu devolver pra minha cidade o que
eu tô devendo pra ela que é poder travar
essa luta aqui dentro junto com vocês
a gente tem 600 mil árvores dentro desta
cidade
a imensa maioria são nativas algumas não
são mas a imensa maioria é de aves
nativas
a prefeitura não cadastrou essas aves
alguns municípios já fizeram isso a
nossa prefeitura não fez
e essas aves estão aí vocês ver o que
acontece nas ruas da cidade quando tem
uma chuva forte às vezes eles querem
derrubar diz que não precisa ser
derrubado os moradores correm se
penduram e teclas movimentações que vira
e mexe aparece nos jornais como a gente
poderia juntar todo mundo para cadastrar
essas árvores de uma maneira que a gente
conhecesse os nomes as espécies vice
aquelas que precisam de cuidado se
alguém precisa de semente pudesse usar
essas sementes também como a gente podia
fazer isso e eu comecei a pensar
novamente em tecnologia e porque não
desenvolveu um aplicativo de celular
as pessoas fazem check na árvore e meio
no como se fosse uma grande equipe e
todo mundo participar deste negócio só
que já tinham criado esse negócio lá na
califórnia graças a deus colocaram como
software livre disponível para quem
quiser se adaptar e aí a gente adaptou
esse aplicativo ele está disponível por
enquanto só para a cidade de são paulo
a gente pode colocar ele pra fazer
trabalho em qualquer cidade mas a gente
está começando por aqui até para fazer
uma experiência as pessoas vão começando
a baixar e aí a cadastrar as árvores não
se conhecer o nome negócio de marcos
valle tira fotografia ela está mapeada
alguém depois vem coloca o nome
científico e assim a gente vai na boa
vontade na colaboração de todo mundo
fazendo isso juntos e esse é mais um dos
elos nem a gente já tem a plataforma
para viver histórias têm essa daqui pra
nós todos não é para qualquer pessoa
usar a gente agora está criando uma loja
online de sementes que não existe no
brasil nenhuma loja online de sementes
florestais então eu trabalho no qual a
gente está se jogando agora e tudo isso
se conecta de além disso tudo a gente
conta histórias histórias de pessoas que
amam árvores então podem ser histórias
no brasil fora daqui ea idéia é a gente
poder compartilhar isso com todo mundo
porque vai ajudar a mover se ela da
restauração florestal se vocês pegarem
esse aplicativo porque a gente vai
primeiro espalhar o conhecimento
depois a gente vai compartilhar o amor
que a gente tem pelas aves e no futuro
pode ser que cada um de vocês e eu tenho
amigos conhecidos que compra um terreno
precisa do licenciamento ambiental
existem várias questões envolvidas e
restauração florestal e tom
os nós de alguma maneira vão estar
ligado nelas nem que seja só para
garantir a água que tem que sair das
nossas torneiras
então é homenagem para o meu ipê roxo
tac na interface web do viva floresta
ele é uma piada na rua sagarana 133
entre a vila madalena alto de pinheiros
onde a minha mãe ainda mora vocês
passarem nada uma olhada por favor faça
o download e vamos lá salvar cada um as
suas duas árvores não é isso aí